[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants mais qu'est ce que
tu fais de nous
une seconde pas trop
j'écoute ce que me dit mon petit doigt
ah bon et peut-on savoir 7 il te dit il
m'a dit qu'il faut que je descende tout
de suite chez nicolas et pimprenelle car
ils ont reçu une belle surprise on le ch
l europe a tout de suite pas trop à tout
de suite ne retrouve pas papa
papa maman est ce qu'il y avait dans les
facteurs il a dit que c'était pour nous
bonsoir du color bronchera pas preneur
regarde le panier qui vient d'arriver
c'est le facteur qui nous l'a apporté
mon petit doigt me l'avait dit
et il contient une belle surprise
voyons un peu ras une lettre
adressée à nicolas
et à patronale
je lis cher patronne elle ne pleure plus
poupet est arrivé hier soir chez nous
[Musique]
à qui
elle va rester quelques temps en
vacances car elle a besoin de repos je
t'envoie une poupée tout neuf pour que
tu ne t'ennuies pas
cher nicolas
tu trouveras au fond du panier un bon
cerveau lens car
maman
si vous voulez venir passer des vacances
chez nous dans notre roulotte à bientôt
sinue
cornichons
[Musique]
qu'elle est belle
ah oui elle est belle
et voilà le cerf-volant saint nicolas
aux
gens même la campagne pour le cerveau
les mois
alors oui
[Musique]
bonne nuit les petits
bonne nuit ou plus dit nounours tu crois
qu'on va vraiment aller en vacances
c'est qu'en échange il faut demander à
votre maman
[Musique]
la jette un la lune un
fait pour
alors nounours ton petit doigt avait
raison
la surprise était belle formule pas trop
bonne nuit des enfants allez vite vous
coucher le fait pour eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]